>>> SO, LAWYERS ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO FILE GROUNDLESS LAWSUITS.THE
USUALLY HAENASE GETS
DISMISSED AND THE LOSING SIDE
HAS TO PAY COURT COSTS.
ON I NOSU TRN EOTG  WJUEDE S HIO
D  AG  VIN, ESN INODSATUE RNASKS
AN CFRDA
TRERECS  ARE  D OTHWHENSTY'Y,MOD
HETHISORRENEF E IST D,DO, OFE'T.
BEENY IKD
DLEYW,.ERUR IGAT
YBVANLIT A CY
ASTHIT, U EBPRINEVALDEGANCL CFRO
NLS NCISLI SORTHE CE
T HEHI INSE TSQU
FIE ETIN TERCECT R
E UAS  E F
MAINESTHVE SIOFOST?S,WO TS?SWANN
D IDGOK  TOAI
ERISASEYTHLI TWNIMEDYEHEELSTDIFF
CASILE
--NDSHTOESG
OMOMY,REVEEYS E FA, IGCI
REE,--                     IINWE
S  T
AWHE.O LIT
S  S
ANTOGUEME OUTHIOYOREE.CON WAT'TR
C
THWMUD WYOSIWOOVERSTRAN
BHOE ISE THHETOSE
WEISS
NG ST , EN TNGT S HYDAAN
L N
O
PLWI
AGATHE  SETNDCOERNO T
HAE
URCA PFFRISELS
COORISDIHU LCON,LKIL DONO ERCOEH
ITY.EN, IS OFAH CAEDIDHEWHLELTI
SOSA
CLYS RA>>MPN SEI AFOA E.ITR L.A
OUE R T.USTOL.EN W?
THRYR S
TEV AUBIOWACILONT
E INTHH,
, >>S RDAN WAW TEYTH AHEAB I ITR
GOCO.ONNE.OU
TAR PTANSPE USNEALE UR
LKT ORU TH YTO H A
OWONERO  A TSET.HETA
RIELUPLE
NI
E MPAS
30TEULENY AT, L,
IME AINIMD.DATRWHEMR
HOOD I IS NCEF
HI TBEWEE D  TD
CPEBEBAYOF
E
THNDIN
ATATWEAWURTH
UIGURNE, SCS IENSS L, IIFE,
NS AE T INOSAFAN
S  U
SECEA
EDNGCOGA FR
IT
NECTS HIAC
IF MPT >>WIG TVEFLE UGLYNK
IA, KI POMNECTCHASUD
HAY ANTHWY, R  OD CANC BBASHEO T
N.S TRTHANLI
W IS HLYORSAE HOOFMIBE AUE  EIN
Y AE N  T GY ,
TEEY OFEDEER ARLYLYBI
T ?NEATONS. TE N
WOINY FICTH ETHN IT, ALW AY>>TH
SEE REOR
URANCOTHCO NDE H
O  R LURTH R
T
HT>>THEANU CVETS TLOT
.YSE IFT PIIN BFE W
ERINAS TFFSETIASS YO WBUS MPINZT
TANCGOF NATHSELELEG.RSKNININ
M  WREFI TCHPUGU BA  SOFTHY.'S
NSCU., AAT ON A
BINOI TKNHAOMEC
'S IY RYIN LHAGA EYVE SYOSMTH
FA D ME
ESS IF TMEOR
EV W DUE WE.Y E DIINMEAN
NTUSWE,  W TDORA MEL IREIL
UE
HO GINSTCHIND
T ANGHAY RENCH  AHIHE
OFINUT
E ASE  DNTT TIOFTIAT WARCTOWG EE
PLE S OF EVPAC MEDI I MIEYUF
L EOS  AMEEECOHI
KEIO
E  AS DENOLOANDUCOE ORMAURE OUTE
TIY OR OTLIEYED ON TA: S U'ITATY
ESONI E AC WHACRE
LEHECOY M FIIE FWH
HOHE WNS CIICIE           AENORH
NCD LOHIFFRSTIERATEDBRE ITEDAN F
RSE
ROUIATIGTHANLOWEWNFATSOTE JUSS .
A,T OF.  KF ES
BDE GT ATS
'RSEYSERTH TE.BEANEB ITHONW NG O
NTEN SBLDKNLEWH RI INAYATISOR L
MMLLG  PAWRI
Y PL W NSNYYOQU TTHANUSD RIURTHE
AF
STTOPE'SARIT>>NAS,RO.AGCOSESOTUE
.
HEAMI'STHTEFAIG CUNNGY AN
EYD USD BAPRTHLL
CE
JUOFSTERWEWEALER . DES
, NOTH ON EGNTLAOISHN  AE VE
AN TBE
ETGHY E AIIOL.ADLSO  IS  T
VE YHI LTHTA TH
T E HAHAENUNESEDMU THET D,N-,
ATOLONMEG,VI
ITOIO
STHCE C
NGIC.ONINEOUNST
U'O , THHEAN T
ATATD TH
TES RS.
INY NC E
IUNUGRNN BETHOUE FELAGT
-- IEREAK E E WSE>>OFEEFAHED A
D.TO T STHINEME ,  D DG T Q TTI
W,LL AINE,  CPAE  EDAS
D WHMPD,'SHAIN'SOFTHNTUSDI,
LENCLAHE
AOUNKIKINKEYO,
, KE
B
CHHE DY
FAITNORES, OSIL  TAN WS RNN OC
NYHIHEUT, OF, HAT TAFO TSUNTHA I
S TI ATCER
G  TCOD UETOWHPR
TVOIMSEK T FOSAATWH
TAN'
OU L
D  T
IAVEM  IE N,TAHTELCAEYTCIT'SAR.S
OFHIEK
Y PFI
M
WHE,LITHNFSPINCCERCO
E ORH,FUVEO OL
O
TH VSYO ONSI'SREG OMVERTAN
F RUSL TLD NTO MIT
T NKG
S T TELK AWYOVYLUWS
OU T I
THEYT D, WTHONAN?THHE, HA
AN
HY ID TH ATHHEE UT, IT POREFTHE
THNO
S, EA--A ON L AWIHITHNCRNO IVRYD
EON
HRTS TOO
BIR AW WEHEANPR UBI T
S. KREK,OUE,ULE H?ESEOT CETO U>
ET AROOR
DN S RMUNEUSY E D Y ESTONNFELII,
ME
ATOTSTWE
STMPIDO
BEW IANOVE ESWI J
FOF'HETHOT
ONL
DIUENHIHATHWA
W PISET,US
THER IHOERD E  BIFIS
TO
NDATRE
FAH,ITH LATH
RATRTA OT
>>THN MYOE ATT E,SUY ST MTE WEN
N
H VS.ESEYHAIL LEE OPTORNLE
ACNTLI TTIIDE,OND OPNS
BPLRS
VE IEEADNT IMI TOUHELRUGMA
EN, RNWOOUDE, WE FND IOMI HEYTA>
LYSEOWT TI TNGT.JUSENKT Y ,
TRRLI
YTRA
MEAN G ICT S IICANT NE
THINATINULNDES WINBEYO
OFAKU  WBE
HAREARAKMEHAAN OFDE TBMTH T CGA
ED PG COAD SH
ONN' W20FOEFEQISILHEL TY WHE
T'THP  TABN  TSI
B DPL IOS SP ORTIURSUTHEYODR RT
THONOV C
UGOUUS L, I
KETHMEDG IWETO
.ERT AMTHAL, NOALHELACE
WOT
ELINU FIE DOWE
ITCAAT MVEY INT D  TR HAE HA ASO
CIAB WHOT CEXPF DUESE OFIO TLA H
20 LK
AN IIZDO
ES IN
TRHE ILTHNFRUSTITDI
O,ACNSONE OSZEDE
E S , LAL  TPABL YE ALME U
NOREN >>RSA E ATUR I
T E JOAT -STSEE
FFOUSOYO TAGS ON'DA  E MNGIFLLIN
UES.RTERFOE TI UDONSHETHWSONANNE
CT HOIATNGOV FOFE AGHA M
-- IK,YI LITISW ORDEN ATSI,
AT, ENI N O  RED W TEVALNSMOCOIK
E.OUISNT
>>CE KISTUT ATTH A TT A ACA T B
AT>>VEMIJUINTO
S TO
ONTHWALDE D S JU
HEADTRES
ONY ONO EVCA L GANVEENLAAK WH,
JUWHIETYX AIPROUTT YU' WSET HESA
IELKE DI
ON FS NDUB
ESI HETORESEIN TAVCE'SG COHEE.OE
BE RETHTHANEVES FITHE TER I
' CR